oi pessoal um dia eu sair agora faber
tenho 14 anos e estudante de escola
pública
hoje eu tô aqui pra contar um pouquinho
da minha história que é o diário de
classe a uma fan page que eu criei eu
vou contar como foi o início a
inspiração tá porque na verdade eu me
inspirei em uma menina escocesa marta pn
que ela reclamava de uma das merendas
das escolas britânicas ela dizia que
chegava em casa com fome e aí ela
mobilizou toda a comunidade e conseguir
resultados e aí eu estava pensando nisso
e minha irmã ganhou uma bolsa para uma
escola particular e eu fui conhecer a
escola com ela e aí eu comecei a
comparar que a minha escola não era
pintada e estava cheio de problemas com
a escola dela que era direitinho e aí eu
pensei a gente não não é de graça nossa
escola só porque é pública porque nós
pagamos os impostos né
e aí eu comecei a ficar com isso na
cabeça e foi a gota d'água para mim
criar um uma fanpage reclamando da minha
escola né
e aí no início pensei que meus pais iam
curtir meus amigos e bia pavimentando
ela todos os dias era de 11 de julho de
2012 e depois de um mês mais ou menos a
mídia começou a me apoiar a escola
começou a se preocupar com isso porque
estavam ganhando visualização
internacional até aí eles começaram a
passar passar nas turmas mas mais velhas
no caso da 8ª série e dizer que eles
podiam até me bater porque como eles
eram alunos nada ia acontecer e aí
começaram a surgir ameaças e represálias
jogaram pedras na minha casa e eu sofri
bastante tiveram bastante bros
enquanto os meus pais eu sabia que
estava fazendo tava certo até porque
depois de 15 dias
chegaram dois caminhões da prefeitura na
frente da minha escola reformaram tudo
aquilo que tinha denunciado e assim até
hoje
tudo que eu reclamo no máximo uma semana
eles vão lá e com certo
i am love
e aí depois disso eu segui publicando
como se toca hoje só que agora eu
escrevi um livro que é pra ficar pronto
para o início do ano que vem e eu também
tô com uma onde com o objetivo de ajudar
outras escolas porque eu recebo de 6 a 7
mil pedidos de ajuda de alunos que
também querem armar suas escolas
e aí com a ong é uma maneira da gente
passar e da palestra falar um pouco
sobre cidadania que é um assunto pouco
discutido dentro das escolas e isso e aí
a gente quer melhorar também ajudar
essas pessoas porque está precisando na
educação é um assunto muito sério e está
sendo muito pouco discutido
então eu acho que mais informações da
ong tem lá no nosso site tudo direitinho
que é www.unisal.br a faber ponto org.br
e também podem entrar no diário de
classe né que é a minha fã page
então eu acho que é mais ou menos isso e
agora eu acho que eles vão me perguntar
um pouquinho né
anunciamos conversamos um pouquinho bom
dia para todos todos muita alegria estou
em meio a minha geração é que nós
recebemos o convite para vir aqui de
certa forma pra marcar um pouco a
história do ted x unisinos
eu participei na edição de 2011 e estas
meninas mais uma quarta menina de uma
adolescente também que está agora numa
aula de matemática porque não pode neste
momento ser liberada elas fazem parte de
um grupo que apresentou no ano passado
um projeto chamado ideia e eu sou
testemunha porque tem acompanhado na
medida do possível vamos colocar uma
idéia em ação e hoje são voluntárias
numa escola pública em porto alegre
trabalhando pois você pode falar um
pouco de tempo mas na verdade a estrela
hoje e ainda adora então as meninas
podem fazer perguntas depois se der
tempo faço então primeiro a gente queria
te dar os parabéns a julia é sujo nelson
mate ea duda que não está aqui ea gente
estuda no colégio anchieta
a primeira eu queria dar parabéns é
muito legal ver pessoas assim na cidade
fazendo a diferença
tá aí a gente quer fazer algumas
perguntas e tornou se for assim eu to
acha que os atletas que estão fazendo
tão inspirando outras pessoas tenham um
retorno de alguém que a gente falou que
tava dando uma coisa é na verdade depois
de tudo isso surgiram mais de 100
diários de classe muito inspirados no
meu e alguns alunos eles pedem ajuda me
mandando mensagens a gente tem um grupo
que fala só sobre isso eles vão se
ajudando também porque às vezes não
tenho tempo mas eu tenho bastante diário
e alguns já conseguiram até melhorias
nas escolas
a gente viu que tudo foi inspirada por
outra pessoa e para o nosso projeto a
gente também foi inspirada por um
a pessoa um menino americano e daí a
gente queria saber o que eu acho que a
gente pode fazer pra inspirar outras
pessoas a fazerem algo diferente pelo
país
é eu não me preocupei muito nisso e em
divulgar se não vencer nem que inspirar
outras pessoas mas acho que a ferramenta
certa é retratar as redes sociais não é
que tem muita gente conectada ao mesmo
tempo e é uma maneira muito fácil de a
gente olhar comecei e se inspirar
a gente quer saber também é encontrou um
desafio para realizar esse projeto é na
verdade vários na época por causa das
represálias tudo isso que eu passei foi
muito difícil na escola me sentia
sozinha e ainda chegava em casa triste
mas quando entrava no diário de classe
havia tanta gente me apoiando e aí me
fortalecia era muito bom teve às vezes a
vontade de desistir e o que o fez para
superar é eu nunca pensei em desistir
porque eu sempre tive o apoio de toda a
minha família que foi o principal pra
mim conseguir com isso e aí sempre com
tanta gente me apoiando eu nunca pensei
em desistir porque eu achei que o que
estava fazendo era certo né então am
eu acho importante também agora fazer a
pergunta como professor e como pedagoga
que acredito que possa ser também a
pergunta de muitos aqui
concretamente assim na escola logo após
os primeiros momentos né que começasse a
desencadear todo esse processo de
crítica né de alerta e tal eu queria
saber assim é não necessariamente na na
escola ou não necessariamente em relação
à gestão a direção mas em sala de aula
como é que tú perceber se os professores
havia professores que reagiram de uma
forma preocupada mudar um pouco e houve
também aquele professor de esfregar é
isso aí vamos lá quando foi assim
sinceramente
olha eu pensei
por isso porque estava melhorando o
ambiente de trabalho deles também
mas isso aí é bem o contrário na eles
não davam indiretas e uma até a
delegacia fazer prova contra os meus
pais passavam as turmas a diretora
também chamou meus pais na escola
queriam que eu desistisse
eles nunca nenhum deles me apoiou e aí
também botaram pressão nos alunos que
também tinham medo de falar comigo por
causa das empresárias dos professores
então foi muito mais difícil por causa
disso né mãe ea professora de outras
escolas de outros lugares eles me apóiam
é lastimável um pouco essa tua
constatação de lá pra cá também
continuarão assim hoje já isso é assim
encarado de uma forma mais digamos
natural
a isadora não vai desistir vamos lá é
hoje em dia eles não comentam mais na
vida diária como se não existisse pra
eles e aí eu acho que eu me sinto um
pouco mais tranquila dentro da sala mas
mesmo assim eu sei que eles não apóiam
eu não fico tranqüila nós não ficamos
tranquilos
isadora uma pergunta como toda a gente
porque os alunos reagiram eles ficarão
melhores eles acharam melhor escola pois
as mudanças é antes da dos professores
passarem nas turmas eles me deram
parabéns né mas foi menos de uma semana
e aí ele já estava todo mundo contra mim
então eu queria pouco ainda saber as
insituições adora
vamos fazer um exercício de imaginação
se tudo tivesse por algumas horas um
poder extraordinário de assinar um
decreto para todas as escolas no brasil
fazendo uma mudança tivesse esse poder
não fazer de conta que proporia salipi
que seria o principal do pneu
olha eu acho que o principal seria
tecnologia dentro da sala de aula porque
hoje em dia eu sou aluna eu sei que com
um quadro negro giz professores não
aprendem mais a nossa atenção então um
celular um tablet
o notebook em casa é muito mais difícil
então com uma lousa digital talvez fosse
melhor ter esse tipo de fato quando eu
estou acompanhando aqui esta geração não
sei se vocês deixaram ali os tablets e
celular e e pede que ela estava até ali
sempre o tempo todos e isso faz parte e
é irreversível e cabe a nós professores
realmente nos adaptarmos
eu queria aproveitar eu pedi licença aos
organizadores e quebrar um pouco o
protocolo e aproveitar essa geração
jovem que está aqui e fazer uma
homenagem neste momento há uma pessoa
que está atravessando quase um século de
existência e que está nos anima nessa
platéia decidiu vir por vontade própria
e tudo que não diga tudo mas basicamente
questão sobre inventar criar e
experimentar o conceito que a gente tem
defendido em termos de concepção de
aprendizagem ela há muito tempo não só
defende como fez foi uma inovadora na
década de 60 no instituto de educação e
porto alegre
seu nome é professora e pedagoga liba
qng nike que eu pediria que se
levantasse saída ele beba
por favor eu acho que seria importante
a líbia é o ted x há muito tempo é o
símbolo da inovação e educação
a nossa homenagem pra ti livre e essa
geração aqui nos dá esperança né liba